i'm happy to be here
so today i'm going to talk to you about
considerations for
collaborative robotics
so i mentioned i direct the arm lab
which stands for the assistive robotics
and manipulation laboratory
in our lab we focus on three main
research areas robotic assistance
intelligent wearables and connected
devices where the idea of robotic
assistance is
you have these robots that are able to
enable and amplify the efforts of a
human collaborator or possibly perform a
task for them
intelligent wearables are robot systems
that are usually augmenting the person
and provides situational awareness and
help the person achieve their objective
and connected devices again have the
situational awareness
but usually don't have any sort of
mobility and their goal is to anticipate
service needs and so our overall goal
is to develop intelligent assistive
technology that improves
human life so when we really look at
this sort of problem we focus on
um a the robot which you know is uh
essential to robotics how does a robot
model itself
how can a robot model a complex task but
when you want robots to be collaborators
it becomes really important that they
also
model the human and so this graph is
going to come back throughout this talk
but this is really the epicenter of the
types of questions that we ask
so here is a actually partial list of
the graduate and master's students
in the arm lab currently and they work
on a host of different
projects so uh let's start off by
thinking about the timeline of robotics
itself
so in the 80s up till about the 2000s
you know when you thought of a robot you
thought of a system
that was helping with automation so
doing some repetitive tasks possibly on
an assembly line
and it was extremely important that
those robots be very precise when they
executed their task we saw the
movement toward autonomy where now the
robots had to perceive
unstructured environments and understand
their place in it
in order to function well we saw the
onset
of swarm technology centralized systems
and then even decentralized systems
where these big teams of robots need to
work together
in order to accomplish a larger goal
and now in the past decade we've been
approaching
augmentation so how can these robots
work effectively
with human counterparts when there might
be limited communication
so what does effective human robot
collaboration
possibly look like i'll give a few
examples
that are actually very pertinent because
actually projects within my lab
and they include possibly wanting robots
to work with humans to carry objects
you can imagine a wearable system where
you want to detect
where a person will walk possibly to
alert them that they might possibly fall
you might want a robot to be able to
learn how to do a new task
and work alongside a person such as
carrying boxes from one location to
another
you might want to have an intelligent
prosthetic that can interpret a human's
intent given the environment and limited
inputs from the person
to execute a task you might want to have
shared autonomy between
a robot here a vehicle and a person so
that
the system knows when and how to
transfer control between the human and
the robot
and maybe even more passively in that
sort of connected
devices phase if you want to have
a system that can help observe the
environment and do interpretation to
help a person
understand the people in the environment
around them
so we're going to focus on three main
questions the first being
what makes an effective collaborator
what tools do we have in robotics and
what do we need
to make the robots effective
collaborators and finally what must be
considered
for human robot teams
so what makes an effective collaborator
so here is a a a good motivating
video of a swarm of robots here they're
coordinated quadrotors that are flying
together
and they all know where to be because
there is um an
oracle a single system that's telling
every agent
where to go here you can see that is a
sort of base station that's commanding
them where to go
and this is being achieved through
digital communication
but as these teams might possibly get
larger
it might actually be too much for a
single oracle
um to handle and that limitation might
be due to computational complexity or
even just
range if you imagine all of these
quadrotors that you see
here if they were to expand in their
function or even be over an entire city
it might actually be very difficult for
an oracle to
govern the second to second or
millisecond to millisecond action
and so they have to be decentralized and
communicate with each other to achieve
that but again
if you look at what the state of the art
is a lot of this is in fact
digital communication as a method to
drive this and we'll talk later about
how these robots themselves even reach
the sort of consensus
which is the shared plan agreement on a
shared plan
but the problem definitely gets harder
if you think about wanting to
collaborate with
biological systems or agents so here you
have an example of
basketball players that are working very
well to do an
operation tempo op tempo task here of
scoring on these teammates in a very
fast
play and they clearly don't have digital
communication
so what makes an effective team i would
postulate that this
includes having shared goals and
objectives among teammates
the ability to model teammates behavior
for prediction
and finally the ability to plan given
personal
and teammate roles
so clearly communication is extremely
important
um in this uh in this paradigm of
teamwork
and if you think about biological
systems here like these
collies that are hurting these ducks for
sport into the ring as you see here
usually the three main areas are audio
vision
and tactile so if you have audio
communication
this allows for extremely high
specificity um you know
such as giving this talk and passing
information but it can be very slow
and if you have a very fast operation
that might not be adequate
and it's very sequential i speak then
you speak
if you consider vision this can be done
mutually we can directly observe each
other
and so the information exchange can be
extremely fast as you see
in this video and very detailed
so here this is uh sort of
instantaneously they're watching each
other the dogs are watching each other
and knowing what they should do in order
to
achieve the desired behavior but you can
also observe
a very complex description through
vision visual observation as well so all
of us are very familiar with how
honeybees are actually able to
perform a dance and that is visually
observed by
the other insects in order to know how
to operate and find
a target um location
finally for tactile touch and forces can
be
a communication method or modality
that's extremely fast here you see
how quickly the outcome of this
score is able to be conveyed to the
person who is
learning that information through
tactile feedback but here a key
uh requirement is that um proximity
uh must be bounded you have to be close
enough right to touch the person
so a few key features for teamwork i
would say are role understanding
and interagent trust so role
understanding
will classify as given the actions of
others what is my role
and is my role unique given the task
here the robot joins the circle
is this the only place that could join
if another were not in their place could
it
swap with their location what's the role
of this new agent
and agent trust is essentially the
conditions you need
before you take action and you know that
um your actions will not lead to
some sub-optimal behavior this is the
main primary assumptions you're basing
this on
and they consist on of having an agreed
objective and a known behavioral model
so for this uh case with these two cars
um the basis for the red car trusting
the blue car is
it believes that the blue shares the
objective that it doesn't want to
collide
and the behavioral model that to achieve
that objective the blue will maintain a
particular velocity
and based on that trust the red may take
the action of changing lanes
so what are the limitations when you
think of these types of systems so we
clearly see
that you know limited communication
modality you can clearly share a lot
more if you could be digital
you have limited dexterity and strength
to weight ratio and possibly
limited perception but how does
biological systems actually overcome
these they do this through understanding
um the role of the given team and for
the task
they think about that task modeling how
do you model the task and they think
about that teammate
modeling as well
so if we kind of want to match these two
things together and make robots these
sort of
super effective teammates the next
question question we need to ask is what
tools do we already have in robotics
that can make robots effective uh
collaborators
so i'll break these into three main
categories that are
worthy of note you have proprioception
and control
or the sort of knowledge of self you
have perception where you're sensing the
environment
you can think of computer vision or
tactile sensing and intelligence or the
ability to model
and make decisions so going into
proprioception and control this is does
the robot know
where it is in space so these are pretty
easy this is more hardware you can think
of
your encoders that are able to sense
your four kinematics
and if you have a model of yourself how
much do each one of your links weigh
what is your torque or input capacity um
you can quickly
model the dynamics of your system here
the torque is your input
you have an inertia uh coriolis
centrifugal terms and possibly gravity
on our way towards control this also
means you need to know how to
move within yourself possibly without
avoiding self-collision
so motion planning becomes a really
important part if you think of systems
like manipulators
usually for high dimensional systems you
kind of find yourself in this sampling
category in order to achieve your target
pose
and finally control how does the state
change
given a function of what the state
currently is
and your choice of inputs again for a
manipulator you can think of torques
at every joint so digging a little bit
deeper into the space of controls
particularly if you're interacting with
your environment because again we're
thinking about this sort of tactile
sensing
can you feel a force being applied or
how do you react to
your environment doing force on you um
two primary ones for this sort of
contact scenario is impedance and
admittance control
where essentially impedance the goal of
impedance is to have a desired
um dynamical system particular mass that
you want to have the system behave as if
that's how much mass it had and resist
motion
impeding motion and for admittance
control you want to say if i have some
target behavior and i have some input i
want to actually admit that behavior i
want to move in the way that's being
asked of me
and depending on your different scenario
one of these or both of these might be
useful so you can think of an impedance
case where if you want to actually push
a door open
you want to actually have a particular
amount of force you want to apply
so impedance is great but if you're
interacting with a human and you were to
think about safety and you were to
accidentally bump them
you definitely want to have an
admittance controller
in the space of perception you can think
of
camera sensing as being extremely
important here you see autonomous
vehicle
camera looking at its surroundings able
to classify the different elements that
are present
you can think of laser range finders
that are able to
literally send out light and use that
reflection to give you information about
your environment with precise distances
if other conditions are allowed
and finally tactile sensors right so
sensors that can actually feel forces
possibly both normal and shear in their
environment
so in our lab we realize that this
tactile sensor is a really big barrier
to having
robots really present in your home and
so
we asked the question right what does it
take to really get us there
and so here on the left you see this
video
of this place oh
excuse me that crashed uh well you had a
video
of uh one arm that was actually
manipulating an object
and on the right uh we have a video of
gelsite that will be back in one moment
but is really using vision to actually
look at the boundary
of a sensor to give you information
about it
one moment as it pulls up and so that's
really the question right so the first
video that we were looking at
you had this this robot that was capable
of
manipulating an object in hand but the
way that that actually worked was they
had external cameras that were looking
at the
rubik's cube and they had spent hours in
training
learning how to um actually manipulate
that object in hand without
it dropping out of the robot's hand
so if you really look at this sort of
space of
manipulators and where we've come the
state of the art for quite a while was
these sort of biotech sensors
so they have smaller resolution than
these vision-based sensors
but they're really effective then we
have the onset of like gel site
and so here this is the digit using gel
site and it has a camera inside that's
looking at that flat surface you see
there
and it's able to detect impressions
there that give it both
normal and sheer forces but it's very
flat so we call that a 2d
shaped vision based sensor and we
finally have this
um 3d shaped vision based sensor here
coming out of berkeley omnitech
where there are tiny micro cameras
looking everywhere
so locally they see a flat image because
they're so close to the surface
but the whole sensor itself is curved
in 3d
so in our lab for this work in tactile
sensing
we really realize that we can break this
whole thing up into three main questions
the design
the modeling and the motion planning so
we're asking can we
leverage anthropomorphic inspiration
incurred fingertips
that are capable of deforming and
sensing friction to drive our design
for modeling can we effectively model a
continuously curved fingertip
with high resolution and characterize
stable grasps
and finally if we have that design in
that model can we leverage this
efficient
continuous model of our fingertip to
plan multi-finger graphs
for in-hand manipulation
so this work performed by my phd student
juan kim do
really looks at how can we make this
curved uh sensor design
and after a few iterations we converged
on actually using a fisheye lens
looking at a curved um hemispherical
fingertip where the radius center for
the
fisheye lens and the sensor are shared
and it gives us some really nice
features in terms of
our image model for the system
and so this whole sensor and whole setup
is pretty low cost
and has some really cool features and so
far has been performing
quite well for us so you can kind of see
the leds which are inside that are
rotating
um for um contact um so they're moving
really slowly so you can see them but in
real time when we would do them they
would be moving much faster closer to
the rate of the camera and the idea of
having such a system perform this really
allows us to
um observe the shadowing that's produced
when you actually
imprint on the surface so in the middle
figures and on the left
you can see this sort of notion and so
if the
camera if the leds actually rotate then
this can give us a whole bunch of
perspectives to compare
so that we can actually get a particular
impact a sort of quasi-static
impact from multiple points of view
and so right now we're going one step
further to say
can we actually calibrate this and
actually know
the depression as well as the forces
given
our system so um once this design has
been completed and finalized
uh we'll move on to modeling and motion
planning as well
and some ideas for this are if you have
this ability to measure the normal and
shear forces which these type of vision
sensors give you
and if the surface is actually soft and
can conform to whatever it is that
you're contacting
then through vision you can actually
determine how the surface was deformed
and what the forces both normal and
shear were
everywhere and this is the basis of what
you need to actually build what we call
a wrench cone
which essentially tells you how much
force you can apply
and moments you can apply before
slipping occurs
and particularly what's nice about these
vision based sensors is besides just
seeing the boundary
because you can actually see the
depression you can know where you are
inside of the wrench cone
and so if you want to plan in hand
manipulation similar to this sliding
work
um where they actually were having a
non-zero velocity for us we're thinking
about in-hand manipulation so zero
velocity
but you can use these sets of motion
clones to to plan your overall action
and so if you think about competing
methods that just directly jump in with
rl
and don't have the benefit of these sort
of motion cones
or wrench cones it's going to take them
a lot longer to learn but if we can
mathematically represent these we think
this is a tool that will cut down
the rate of learning for these other
methods
exponentially so
the last phase i'll talk about for them
uh in the ones that i mentioned is
intelligence
right and so if you think about all the
different types of
models you can use and we'll focus
specifically on
tools that you would use um for
predicting the behavior or actions
of either yourself or other agents
notably
commented as trajectory forecasting they
break down into a few different
categories and i love this breakdown
coming out of marco pavone's lab here at
stanford
you have ontological methods which
believe that there's some underlying
structure
to how the decisions are being made
or how the state is changing and those
can be state space models or internal
cost functions
and then you have on the other side
these uh
phenological uh methods these
data-driven structures
so these can be deterministic regressors
or even
uh generative approaches and so based on
what uh what you actually have in these
assumptions that you're making about
your system
some may be better than others and a lot
of our work we assume
that there may not be particularly
because we're trying to predict behavior
these really nice ontological methods we
may be able to pull from
and this pushes us more and more toward
these sort of generative
approaches so finally thinking about
where robots are and where
you know we'd like to be you know common
algorithms for corrupt
uh cooperation for robots um can be
categorized as either having an oracle
that's telling all agents what to do all
agents could
in fact act independently toward a
predetermined goal and not really
interact but just assume that everyone
knows what they should do and where they
should be
and then finally you have consensus
through voting systems
in terms of the digital space where they
share information and they converge on a
solution or an action
based on that shared information but
most of these implementations are
conditioned
on the availability the availability of
digital communication
and so this is something that we have to
rethink when you want to actually have a
human in the loop
so what must be considered for these
human
robot teams so
again that key challenge for the human
robot team is digital communication may
not be available
right so what do robots need to be
effective teammates for humans
i postulate that they need the ability
to model complex tasks
the ability to interpret and manipulate
environments configured for humans
and finally the ability to model
teammates actions and roles
so i believe you can also further kind
of categorize
robot collaborators as wearables and an
external
collaborator one is augmenting the human
and the others
kind of performing like a partner and so
in the wearable space
you actually can see the ability to
substitute
substituting device so this
wearable is actually performing the
function of part of you
or perhaps an ability enhancing device
such as a phone
so let's get into the ability
substituting devices
so here you actually see a human on the
left
and i can kind of think of this control
diagram where the human has some
cognition
they're planning what they want to do
their brain knows what kind of
controller they need to execute it
you send that to your body those
electrical signals to your body which
acts
and then you have some sensory feedback
that's telling you
what happened after you took that action
and so for particularly for wearables
the question we need to ask is what part
of the human being is being augmented
or substituted and if we do is the robot
augmentation
functionaling adequately and does the
presence of the robot feel
natural or easy to use
so to answer this my phd student shivani
gupta sarma
and master students gabriella here they
are looking at what we call the
intelligent prosthetic arm
so traditionally in the space of upper
limb prosthetics
you have some power prosthetics and
others that are
body powered as you see here for
shoulder disarticulation amputees and as
you see
this can be very challenging for them to
manipulate even though they're actually
doing a fantastic job
just a limited dexterity can just take
them longer to perform some tasks
so we're thinking how can robotics
actually help
and if you can kind of zoom in here on
the center figure
we're proposing a powered arm
that's informed by the person wearing
emg
signals leveraging augmented reality
and um a robot arm that's outfitted with
the ability to perceive the environment
as well so kind of exploding um
that methodology and going back to that
original figure
um i put on like the second slide uh
here
you know how does the robot sense the
person
right you have these emg measurements
that's how the human is um
sending information to the robot but
what's really difficult a lot of times
is
ascertaining human intent and that line
between the human and the environment
is usually very difficult to sort of
intercept
and so augmented reality mixed reality
that has both the ability to portray
information to the person
as well as extract information from what
they're focusing on
can be a key tool in intersecting that
component
between the human and the task and
environment which can allow us to better
model
the human because we understand what
they're thinking about with the
environment and how they're
interacting directly with us the robot
so let's go back to that sort of
control diagram you have that cognition
which is a planner controller
you're sending some electromyography
signals some
impulses to your muscles which are your
actuators your body has some dynamics
that it acts through
and you have some sensory feedback touch
and vision so clearly we have all of
these
capabilities maybe to a lesser extent in
some cases
but present in robotics cognition right
the ability to plan and control
your plant and actuator body dynamics
sensory feedback touch
and vision so if i look at this sort of
expanded
um uh uh control diagram the planner
controller actuator body dynamics vision
touch and this is all interacting with
your environment and task on a bigger
control loop if you will
then if you have a prosthesis this means
that the actuator and body dynamics are
usually
not available right and so someone with
just a simple prosthesis
would command a robotic prosthesis um
through
say emg if you think about a powered
reflex possibly with some basic reflexes
like maybe
heat or contact then maybe you want to
outfit that prosthesis with the ability
to have
some sensory feedback like vision or
touch so if the person is moving and
they impact with the wall
it might respond immediately um but it
doesn't really think
and the person is still controlling with
emg finally you can even have a system
where the person has the ability to play
and control
but the robot also using the vision and
touch of the environment can also
understand its role and can help the
human um to be
a less cognitive load for the person
who's using
the system
as i was mentioning before augmented
reality is a very powerful tool
that can allow the robot to both extract
and present information to the wearer so
the top
two left corner images really show how
with devices like the hololens 2 you can
actually perform
gaze tracking and see what the person is
looking at or thinking about
you can kind of model that as sort of a
conic area of focus
which can be very helpful when
ascertaining what the person actually
wants to
manipulate and then if you have
knowledge about your environment
such as affordances or the pose if
you're tracking them or seeing
understanding
this can all be very useful and provide
information back
to the wearer so i want to set this kind
of scene for you if
if you will on how you can imagine the
system ultimately working
so um let's look at this activity of
daily living
adl of drinking some fluid with a
picture of water to refill your cup
and uh feeding yourself from this plate
of food and you have this simple state
machine here
on the right um so you know when you're
getting ready to start off you have two
choices you could grasp the pitcher or
you could grasp the fork
here this little circle with the plus
sign designates where the person's
area of focus is let's say from just
the ar is focusing on
and then that allows you to actually put
more weight on the state machine to
transitioning to pouring
say the pitcher and so when you're
pulling the pitcher
you have two options you could be either
filling the cup or replacing the pitcher
but maybe vision isn't as helpful in
this scenario so maybe here's where you
might actually want to rely more on emg
to kind of
signal which one of these operations at
a high level
you're trying to perform and then
once it's replaced you know options you
might logically go to from there are
drinking from the food
from the cup or possibly manipulating
the fork and if you were continuing to
eat you might trigger this process this
internal process to eat
and if you observe the plate of food
this planting of where the fork should
go next
can be largely handled by the system so
hopefully i've kind of set the scene for
you here
about a very practical way this system
could
ultimately be used so let's define a few
variables
we have the state of the system um s the
gaze
g the emg signal e some desired action a
i and the probability that the human
wants to do a particular action
and we assume that um that set of
actions is
finite and the probability over them
sums to one
so the question uh is we would like to
predict the where is intent based on the
state and behavior so what action do
they want to take
given the state of the system given the
inputs from the amg
given their gaze and we realize that we
want to do that by modeling the humans
behavior what are they doing
with their emg and gays given the states
and available
actions and then have a more
seen sort of contextual understanding
what kind of actions would you expect to
take
given the state of the system
and so from uh bayes rules we actually
have
the following relation right that the
probability of your action given
the emg gaze and state
is equal to this relationship between
the reliance of the
uh electromyography the gaze on the
action in this state
both together and independently on the
state as well as the human intent model
what action you would take
in a given state scenario so if you have
these probabilities um
if you want to predict their intent you
simply take the r max over that
probability and this tells you
what action you might expect the per the
person wants to take
so at this point right this has been a
well-phrased problem and you can
actually branch off into many ways to
solve this
um uh generative approaches variational
autoencoders
particularly conditional variation water
encoders have kind of risen to the top
in a lot of literature as being a
really nice way to solve these type of
problems but definitely not the only way
but here i'll present it here briefly as
the method we're choosing to go forward
with so
x here is your input z is your latent
space and y is your output
so here you have these arrows the black
and red
on the left here that indicate the the
testing process
and the red indicate the training
process
and here there are a lot of resources
you can read that really looks at
the mechanics of this implementation but
simply at the top you want to predict
what is your output given your input
and you can represent that in your
latent space
with the following parameter and
distributions
and so for our task right to actually
solve our problem
we need we realize we need to actually
calculate renditions of the following
um models what is the probability of an
action given the state
and probability of the input given the
state
or given the state and the action so you
could actually have a separate one there
that is just the state
as well so what's really nice is because
we can actually separate these and
combine them at the end
um that separation ability actually
might mean that if we're very careful on
how we choose our states
we can actually train these things
independently
so here you can imagine training an adl
or a task with augmented reality with
able-bodied individuals that can put in
a whole lot of work
and benefit the amputee commit
community by actually putting in that
work and training those models
and then on the other side similar to
conventional prosthesis we can actually
calibrate
by collecting behavioral data for these
specified
actions and so you can imagine if you
had this sort of setup with the
ar system your amg and your prosthetic
if someone has trained how to do a whole
set of tasks and maybe there's a library
or an app store of tasks
right then on the other side if you can
perform a lot of calibration routines
which
cover the space of the actions you would
need to do
then you only need to do that sort of
calibration to calibrate your gaze and
emg to those actions
if you were directly requested to do
them and now your system can
quickly connect to this to the to the
larger space of demonstrated abilities
um and that's our hope to actually
provide um
a great resource in this space and so
that's our objective for the space and
we're in the process of implementing
this
uh now starting off with a virtual
environment a virtual prosthetic arm
performing virtual tasks
so um on the other side here you have
instead of ability replacing devices you
also can imagine
ability enhancing devices so in the
ability enhancing devices
usually this kind of falls under the
category of improving some sort of
sensory
uh feedback concerning the world
so uh one project that we're working on
here with my master's
and undergrad students juno luciana
and our our undergrad student here
what we're doing is we're actually
looking at fall prediction and
prevention using
a smart belt so the motivation here is
the falls of leading cause of fatal
and non-fatal injuries in older adults
age 65 plus
so the question we ask is if these falls
can be predicted can they also be
mitigated
using a wearable sensor that observes
the person and the environment
and so this isn't really new there's
similar work elderly fall risk
assessment
and prediction based on gate analysis
but a lot of this isn't online
work they're not predicting if a fall is
going to be happening on some
significant
time horizon and even those that do are
looking at less than a second or even on
the millisecond scale
but we're saying if you can see far out
in the environment
um what's stopping you from trying to
predict if down the road
uh you might be able to predict the
person might be at risk of falling
and so uh if you observe the person's
gait and surroundings can you predict
the path
that they will take what the gate is
going to be over that path
and the associated risk of falling given
that path and gait
and here we the the actual metric we
take for that is the orientation of
their torso
what's the sway or particularly what's
the variance of the sway to characterize
instability
and so um the idea would be to have on
the person
a camera an imu that is going to be in
the final deployment that you just have
to wear around your waist
and then we would train in order to
allow such a system to correctly
estimate the environment
the odometry the gate and orientation of
the wearer
and once those were successfully
implemented then
the objective would be to use these
inputs with
um some sort of sequential method like
an lstm
to actually predict um the future
trajectory
gate and orientation which is associated
with the fall risk
of the person
again on this sort of ability enhancing
device and more to the connected devices
under uh realm is our asl to english
translation mobile
application so the idea we have here is
you know if you really think about
a lot of translation apps a lot of them
all clearly uh verbal
and in the global community it has been
a raising concern how can we actually
have a good
um automic automatic interpreter for
asl back to english there are a lot of
things companies such as hand talk that
are able to go the other way you say
what you want to say and it shows you
what the signs are but going the other
way
there's not a lot of resources in that
space and those that do as you can see
here on this reference chart
really require a lot of gpu overhead
and so if you want to think about this
being deployable like carrying this
ability in your pocket
we need to do something clever in order
to achieve that
and so that's where our solution space
is how can we actually do this on the
mobile
computing scale and so to achieve this
we're actually leveraging um
transformers to actually characterize
what the spoken words are
and we're doing pre-processing on our
video data
which includes um the ability of
extracting the person's facial
expressions and hands
and now we're actually much better at
doing the torso as well
and correlating those to um the expected
output from the words and so if we can
do that you can imagine being far more
efficient in terms of computation
on your system because you're not
dealing with raw videos
now you're dealing with a subset of key
points that can be very uh
essential for that so moving to the
space
of um external collaborators
here this is work um that's uh in
collaboration with the iliad group and
cs dorsal sadique sadiq
my phd student ely
ing albert and jd we're here
our goal of this project is to model the
cooperative ability of human human
interaction and transport
and transfer it to a robotic assistant
in order to produce an effective
transport
teammate so we realize to be effective
for this
we need to go back to that term of
interagent trust
right which we defined before if you can
uh model the other persons or the other
teammates behavior and actions
then you can understand better your role
in order to carry
um effectively and so in one version of
this
application we're thinking can you
predict where your partner wants to go
given where you've been as a team
s and the actions you both have mutually
taken as well as the environment
oh
in this other space of an external
collaborator
here we have this project efficient
learning from demonstration and
collaboration
with aaliyah smith emmanuel retana
and here the goal is to say hey you know
if you
imagine a scenario where you know you
have first responders you want to do a
duty in an unstable environment you want
to move things
but maybe it's not safe to send a whole
bunch of first responders into a space
maybe it would be great to send a few
first responders
and more robots and there are many
application spaces you can kind of think
of that where
if the robot were able to work alongside
a person you could reduce
risks to that person or people
and so there are two main objectives
within this set of
problems here one is can the human
efficiently teach robot a new task by
identifying critical states using ar
and secondly given the described tasks
can the robot collaborate
learn the human behavioral model and
leverage it to take action that
optimizes performance for the entire
team
so here on uh the uh right
you see um imagine the case of opening a
door
if you go back to one of those google
papers they actually had hundreds like a
bunch of robots
opening a door many many times to be
successful and a huge
problem with rl and learning from
demonstration is really the state space
right but if i were able to define to
the robot what were the important states
it should be paying attention to
you have a rigid object which is a door
you have a constraint which is the hinge
you have the handle is another rigid
object and this constraint
related to the door now there are four
things you need to be paying attention
to
and if you operate these in this
particular sequential
action or state space action then you
can achieve your objective
and so then even transferring this to
new abilities you need to be looking for
these corresponding elements
um will allow robot to understand these
tasks a lot more efficiently
and that brings a lot of power from the
ar side and on the second
objective here if you have these sort of
behavioral models
where you can predict the action the
human would take given the set
maybe their actions are sub-optimal
right if the human carries a heavier box
or all the heavier boxes that the robot
could have been carrying then if you
sum this up over the entire operation
it's going to just take longer because
the human was doing sub-optimal actions
so maybe if you realize the human has a
tendency to carry our heavy things
you should jump in and carry those
heavier things for the robot so you
could think of
any sort of palm tp you know belief tree
solver
using their model to propagate forward
and
explore different trees and then
determine what best action you should
take
that will lead to optimality for the
entire team where you're kind of playing
their scenario
in your mind and this should ring some
bells for you i think in terms of game
theory approaches but
usually in those methods it's
adversarial right you're trying to beat
the person here
you're asking what can i do to be an
effective a more effective teammate and
bring
more optimality to the team
uh this sort of thinking can be applied
to the case
of shared autonomy right so if you
actually look at the space of autonomous
vehicles
a lot of it as we approach level 5 and 6
autonomy is
these cars will become really smart and
we'll just hand over control
and we can just actually just rip the
steering wheel out and we don't need
this anymore
and so i personally disagree i think we
will always want to drive cars
especially as they get
uh newer faster sleeker you know and
elon musk puts out the best next best
tesla
we're going to want to drive it period
and so
if you want to think about how you can
actually get the best of both worlds it
becomes quite essential
to think about how uh handover and
control can be both
safe and smooth um and
uh on top of that right uh you know arc
has been warning us for a long time that
there's going to possibly be some reason
you want to take over i don't subscribe
to that but
um let's let's cater to that and build
for this uh eventuality
so uh leveraging human intent for shared
autonomy
if you kind of think of this controller
and plant paradigm
here you have mh which is a model of the
human
you have mr which is the action policy
of the robot
you're asking what action would the
human take given the states
of the system and the actions that the
robot has taken to date what's the state
transition model
and what is the human action policy so
what's really fantastic with this sort
of setup is
as you're driving if you have a model of
the human
before you actually hand over control
and let it be just a boolean
switch as you might do in a lot of
shared autonomy literature
if you actually just observe their input
for a while you can say
does this input match to a safe set
so let's say you're on the highway and
you're driving around a curve there's a
particular
range or variance that's allowable in
the gas pedal and a
particular range and variance that's
allowable in the steering angle
to actually maintain safe control so if
you have a disconnected input and the
human is
um driving as if they were actually
driving you can monitor
over some finite amount of time what
their input is and if it matches to the
safe set
then you know you can actually blend the
control input safely from the robot to
the human right
and if you're going the other way um
possibly handing over control at
non-zero speeds from the human to the
robot
vice versa all right if something's
going on and perhaps the robot doesn't
sense
something in its path it can react in an
efficient way and particularly
um again ar can play a really big role
because
in addition to risk presentation
right you can imagine the robot's plan
also
being displayed in a sort of holographic
way
in the future in these sort of
windshields and i think that's really
critical for self-driving cars
for us to actually build and maintain
trust of these vehicles
so if you see something or someone
getting ready to walk in your path
and the car is able to efficiently
convey its plan to you
you can actually detect hopefully a
non-frequent but
possible fault right and that would
actually cue you in that you
might need to take some action before
the risk was in fact
imminent
so some takeaways to be effective
collaborators with humans
robots must be able to model human
behavior and their role
there's significant room for improvement
in robotic hardware for alternate forms
of communication such as audio visual
or tactile and robotic collaborators
have the potential to expand
their human teammates capabilities which
will enhance and restore
quality of life thank you
thank you so much i will um
copy paste for those who are in the
audience
please feel free to submit any questions
from monroe
to the google form here for those who
are panelists the 20 or so faculty and
phd students here please feel free to
just unmute and and ask the question
directly
uh i will start with one that i've been
wondering about
it seems like one real strength of sort
of what i'll call the mechanical
engineering approach here is that you
have
um firm models of how the world works
where i think you know a lot of a lot of
us in computer science
you just argue for sort of the unfair
success of pure just like get data and
let the model figure it out and
the i really like the idea of trying to
blend the two that seems like
intuitively it's probably the right
answer
i wonder um how we
manage it when you know there
okay so in the data-driven environment
we have this issue of like well what
happens when we
you know when there's a distribution
shift right so we train over here and
then we see something we've never seen
before and then we do something silly
on the other hand when we're in a model
driven world like you talked about you
know opening the door we can model in a
particular way
what do we do there when we see
something we've never seen before we
have no closed form model for it
like how how would you think about
trying to address these sort of
um new experiences in in this kind of a
world
so that's that's a great question and i
think it has quite a few
parts to it um and brings up a point
that i think is really important i think
ultimately right the at the very basis
of your question is um what if your
model is just wrong
right if you have an analytical model
that's just wrong there's a scenario
you've never seen it's just not present
you're going to suffer the same way as
if you had a data driven model
right so i think fundamentally if you
observe a scenario you've never seen
before and it's not reflected in your
model
you have issues right and then the
question is simply how do you adapt
so like in you know the more mechanical
slash controls paradigm
you know you kind of see the literature
shifting to you know adaptive control
techniques or stochastic control where
we realize okay
we may not always know the answer and
even robust control but we can sometimes
you know double down on our model or
adapt right
um and so i think from that kind of
standpoint
there's a lot of parallel because the
fundamental issue beyond the approach
is still the same right whatever model
you initially had is just not being
reflected in what you're observing
i think however there's a deeper point
i'd like to make
which is a risk that happens
if you um don't really approach
the modeling the correct way so if i if
i were to give you a very large
um you know and i like to think of this
in sort of a manifold
um sort of space the dynamics giving
some state what are some outputs right
if you think of this as a manifold
right if you um have a a few inputs
right that you say okay in this in this
particular uh range
i'm confident on how i'm actually
modeling my system
um but further out right it may perform
less accurately
the key even in regular dynamics or even
in physics right
is to actually you see us uh develop
analytical models that do a much better
job of
explaining the sort of quantum uh
feature if you will
um of whatever it is we're trying to um
describe
right if you think about a dynamical
model i can take
some really you know a big
description of how the state space is
changing but if i try to move toward
generalized coordinates i'm saying
what's the most essential thing i need
to know
in order to predict the behavior how can
i make my model as concise
and generalizable as possible so that it
is both accurate where i've seen it
demonstrated as
well as further out and i'll make a
high-level claim that you know even in
terms of cognitive thinking we do the
same thing
you know physicists if they're
explaining some phenomenon you know
that's way on his face
they're actually their model
descriptions are actually going smaller
to predict larger outcomes that are
further away robots need to do the same
thing
right when we observe the space our
models need to become more quantum
smaller accurate smaller models that are
accurate everywhere
in order to expect them are
generalizable in order to expect them to
be
to behave even further away from where
we did and i would say
you know one kind of big step in that
direction is even
variational you know auto encoders right
you know this is saying i'm looking at
this state
this system and i'm asking can i
compress that information into its most
condensed form and then use that to
extrapolate back
to how you know the world behaves or the
key aspects of how the world behaves
and so i think you know at every level
of cognition
from you know low-level action
controllers to
high-level planners or even you know if
you want robots to think about bigger
questions
we need to follow the trends that humans
do which is make your models accurate
and small
and generalizable so that they can
extend beyond the space that you see
them which means you
truly understand the underlying manifold
that you're trying to represent
and do you as just a quick follow-up on
that do you think that the approach here
is going to be different in terms of
dealing with unanticipated unanticipated
phenomena in the physical world versus
unanticipated phenomena sort of
human behavior world i think
physics definitely gives you the benefit
that
if you stay at a particular scale things
can be considered deterministic
and that can that can definitely help um
but i think you know a lot of times
there are rules that govern just about
everything right
you know true randomness is actually you
know you don't really see that a lot
there's some usually some big guiding
principles i mean particularly in
robotics where you want
to take action and make decisions based
on some phenomena you're assuming
usually that there is some underlying um
description model description that is
there to be obtained
right um so i think that's that's
uh important yeah cool i will um
stop dominating the floor if there are
any panelists or anyone who wants to
jump in with a question
i have more more more to ask but i i
feel like this is not a two-person
conversation
i i have a question so thanks so much
monroe for this really
exciting and and very diverse talk of
lots of different uh topics i think that
is certainly
uh you know intersects between robotics
human robot interaction and
uh yeah i see a lot of overlap with hci
topics as well i'm wondering you know as
you think about
closing this loop between uh you know
basically putting the human
in the loop more and a lot of these
assistive robotic systems
what do you think the the role of that
augmented
reality um you know system can be and
you know are there ways to
to use that in a in a you know more
direct control sense to be able to
provide
you know visual feedback to someone in
terms of you know how they might
think about using their you know sensory
motor control system
as opposed to you know kind of the
higher level of kind of uh
you know basically this is the the
planning or or whatnot are there ways to
you know uh kind of bring that more in
the in this
tighter loop that you showed
yeah so i guess um just rephrasing to
make sure i understand it you know your
question completely
so you know thinking about you know how
ar can play a bigger role in these sort
of
you know feedback control loops how can
it actually play a role on lower level
controls
um for a particular system so i think
absolutely
um they definitely have the ability to
do that
um i would kind of refer back to that
kind of human
control loop um idea again right how
does
our vision directly correlate to actions
that we take
um i think you know on a very
fundamental level you know we have
reflexes
you know so if you see something move
into your field of view really quickly
there's
clearly that kind of response that you
may take but then
on the other side too you know we're
always looking at information and
interpreting it
and making some decision based on what
we see
and what's really fantastic about you
know where ar is actually
going is you actually have both sides of
that right you have
cameras that are out facing which are
localizing the system as well as
observing the environment can be used
for that
and we have a lot of work in computer
vision that's really working to have
better contextual understandings
of environments and then you have the
ability to even
ask questions if you will to the person
by presenting information that you think
is important and what they're focusing
on
or even hypothetical objects and they're
seeing to see how they would react
right to this um sort of uh um input
right so i think with all of that right
you know there's
how does the you know what what a what
does what do your eyes see
and b how does your mind process what it
sees to take some action
you know so i think we're we're getting
well developed on the a
part right which is what can the eye see
and can we interpret that but
modeling how we make decisions based on
some you know set of assumptions of what
we're doing
that's definitely the more difficult
problem uh
to solve but i think by having that sort
of interception right because
whatever you're seeing is literally
being transformed through
the ar if you're doing something while
you're wearing it
then you can kind of be guaranteed to a
point that you're not really missing
anything at least from the vision
perspective
because you're intercepting that data
directly so if they made some
decision based on what they saw you know
the information was present you just
have to figure out what it was
and what was the underlying model that
led to the actions that they took
right and then that that leads to a lot
of interesting um
research one other question that
came up um i will do my best to proxy it
basically putting your working
conversation with some
accessibility researchers including one
who we heard last week
you know your work scene has also some
accessibility motivations
and one of the one of the patterns that
seems to be recurring across the
ability-based design space and the
accessibility space
is that there's essentially a very very
wide space of accessibility needs that
it's you know sort of
bespoke solutions for bespoke problems
because though
my um my abilities may not match
any you know the this one this person's
or that person's or that person's
and i'm wondering again sort of in in
the approach that you're envisioning
how do we do the kind of manual tuning
that we need
to you know to understand this person's
specific model or their own abilities
then map that on to the kinds of support
that you that you that you're building
that's a fantastic question um and one
yet very important to
traditional like assistive technology um
i think you know
when it comes to actually you know
deploying systems for people you know
there's
everyone's needs will be a little
different um
and i think that kind of goes against
traditional sort of engineering
large-scale sort of thinking right you
want to design a solution that has the
maximum impact
as quickly as you can um so i think what
you really
the point you're raising is how do you
think about that sort of adaptiveness
from
a wide scale solution to um
you know the individual's needs
i think again you know framing it in the
context of what you need to do if i
think particularly let's say about like
the prosthetic arm just for an example
the activities of daily living are going
to be similar for everyone
right but generalizability is the key
you know you may open
you know different types of cans than
another person or you may have a
different type of can opener but you're
still
going for the same type of task so that
means
if i'm giving a more general solution i
need a solution that a
understands at a high level what you're
trying to do and without too much effort
can be
adapted to your particular scenario and
that goes both for an outward facing
you know interacting with the
environment and an inward facing
right and that's really important when
you think about amputee
amputees um because every amputation is
not going to be exactly the same right
where do you actually put the emg
feedback sensors in order for them to
actually be able to control
that system right and that's going to be
different for every single person so
for all of these types of adaptation i
think that can
hopefully if you do your engineering
correctly can be closer to a last step
where you have all of these abilities
present in this sort of device
at the end of the day on this technology
and then the last step is then
calibrating that
for a particular individual and if you
actually look at
you know the existing sort of power
prosthesis that use emg
signals there is a whole phase it's just
centered on
calibrating for that person right they
learn to actuate
based on their particular setup so i
think that kind of last step
particularly for devices that are um
serving these sort of assistive needs
like this
um there will be a level of the system
needing to be
particularly tuned for each individual
but hopefully
if you create a system that can be very
generic and can adapt easily
hopefully the overhead for that can be
small and the capabilities the reward
can hopefully be large
thanks i i look forward to that future
i think we all do um well let's thank
our speaker one last time thank you
monroe for joining us
um the we we look forward to seeing you
on campus when we are on campus and in
the meantime i encourage everyone here
if you're interested
in uh if you're interested in this space
to
please uh reach out to monroe you know
we are
still distributed but but one big one
big group so
thanks again and i will uh end the
seminar here thank you